hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to would you rather now
we're gonna be rolling right along I was
looking for other settings like in will
you press the button that could make it
change up but all the best I could do is
create an account that could log up all
of my answers so hopefully we'll get
some new ones and hopefully we'll get
some fun ones so the first one would you
rather only speaking haiku or only
speaking song lyrics now this one would
be great because I could end every
sentence woops it's snowing on Mount
Fuji and that's all I would ever do and
no one would ever question me so I'll
take the haikus oh oh no that would be
much smarter oh because there's a lot of
words and song lyrics Oh that'd be way
smarter I'm stupid
I have tanned every sentence with it
snowing you're not Fuji okay as a leader
would you rather be loved or be feared I
mean usually it's not a choice but as a
leader I'll take being feared would you
rather die on the Hindenburg or die on
the Titanic
so either die in a fiery explosion or
die in the frigid waters of the Atlantic
these both don't seem like very good
choices
oh god no one can decide would you
rather wear only skin tight clothing or
wear clothes that are much too big I
guess skin tight to show off my epic
bond which I have and I guess show off
the rest of me that wouldn't be too good
thing you guys can only see me from the
waist up because ordinarily I'm naked
from the waist down so I'll take the
skin tight clothing thank you very much
would you rather be Lindsay Lohan or
Miley Cyrus oh I have no idea I'm not
good enough to judge this situation I
mean on the one hand Lindsay Lohan's
career is kind of on the way down Miley
Cyrus is still riding a little bit of
Fame she also got a ride a wrecking ball
naked hey Lindsay Lohan did a lot of
drugs
would you rather be the best singer in
the world but ugly or be the worst
singer in the world
but beautiful okay now there's a lot of
good singers out there but you're so
incredibly bad Blake you're you're so
bad
literally the worst singer in the world
that's like a Marvel unto itself
I mean ordinarily I don't sing anyway
and you could have a choice not to sing
but if you're so bad like it's like what
I always say if you're gonna fail fail
as hard as you possibly can
make it such a big failure that people
will write about it for years to come
and hallways talk about it so I'll take
I'll take the bad singing would you
rather slam your hand on top of a
thumbtack with a half inch pin or shoot
yourself in the top of the foot with a
nail gun I'll take the thumbtack that
seems like it'd do less damage I guess
okay
would you rather take a cold shower
every day or take only hot showers just
once every two weeks now see cold
showers are good for you they actually
are like the whole there's a whole
science about exposing your body to
temperature variations and stuff like
that but cold showers are honestly good
for you they suck they suck ass and also
only taking hot showers once every two
weeks it's truer than some might think
and true that I would like to admit
because of a disgusting slob would you
rather drink and drive or smoke and fly
now see it's not being very specific
here it is just generally smoking I
could be on fire and flying nuts a
better option but I would take anything
as opposed to drinking and driving would
you rather be a hawk or be an eagle well
I don't really have any stock one way or
another in this question I guess I'll
take you know what I think everyone
would be an eagle but hawks Hawks are
cool I'll take the hawk I'll be a hawk
even though Eagles probably can eat
Hawks now whatever I'll be a hawk would
you rather have your hands
for dustpans or be swaying jam instead
of sweat hands or dust pans and sweating
jam is such a bizarre thing I actually
don't think I'd mind sweating jam I
could make a living a foot pursuit how
many of you would buy one a bottle of my
sweat and two a bottle of my sweat if it
was a gym I'll take the gym please would
you rather have two sets of twins or
quadruplets does that mean I'm a part of
this or I have children that are this
you know if I had to decide quadruplets
are super rare so I'll go with that
because that's really bizarre and
interesting not that I want to subject
my children to being freaks of nature
but not saying quadruplets are freaks of
nature or twins perfectly fine I'm just
saying how rare and interesting it'd be
alright whatever I'm moving on before
people hate me would you rather not be
able to taste or not be able to smell oh
man seafood is such an important thing I
think I could go through life not being
able to smell anything but if I couldn't
taste food anymore that would be I'd be
tragic I'm stuck with it forever damn it
would you rather hang out with Pooh Bear
or hang out with blue from the jungle
book now I don't know they're both bears
one's bigger than the other one would
also mean I live in the jungle no I
always like Winnie the Pooh I think he's
cool I think he's a cool guy
would you rather catch your best male
friend sleeping with your mom or catch
your best male friends sleeping with
your sister well I don't have a sister
but at least that one would seem more
logical because that could happen in
real life I mean
we're another but I mean I wish my mom
all the happiness in the world I guess
but I think it'd be less bizarre if I
found my best friends leaving with my
sister I guess and also I don't have
let's see oh
Nintendo DSR PSP now this is where my
opinion differs probably from a lot of
people because I bought a Nintendo DS I
don't have one on the regular I bought
it and I was very upset because I hadn't
bought a decent like the old silver flip
one and I bought it and it didn't come
with the charger like that seemed like
the most ridiculous thing did they not
expect anyone to come into this new like
I hadn't bought in years and a PSP
admittedly the battery is just ass but
at least that came with all the
necessary accessories I don't even know
if they make PS PS anymore but I have to
choose the PSP because Nintendo screwed
me over would you rather be a vampire
that can transform into a bat or be a
ghost that can possess only appliances
what's the downside of the vampires and
then like a normal function of the
vampire although being a ghost and only
possessing weird appliances oh man what
if robots eventually become an appliance
and I get to haunt them ooh I'll take
that one you know I'll do that because I
don't know vampires are boring and for
scrubs give me the ghost that can haunt
a toaster any day would you rather lose
an eye in a hand or lose a leg in an ear
huh an eye in a hand I could wear a
sweet eyepatch and have a hook for hand
or have an artificial leg and lose in
here well I mean you can get a
prosthetic ear pretty quickly and just
because you lose the ear doesn't mean
that you lose this the sense of hearing
plus I could have a peg leg can I lose
the end of the leg and the eye and then
I'd be a really cool pirate I'll take
the leg in the year would you rather eat
a pie or eat a grape
hi give me the goddamn pie would you
rather get an atomic wedgie or get a
swirly now if you don't know what an
atomic wedgie
it's a wedgie where they pull your
underwear so far up that it reaches up
over your head and then you're blind
walking around with your balls inside of
your anus
and that's no good for anybody so I'll
take the swirly what people would want
an atomic weight do you not know the
definition of an atomic wedgie an atomic
wedgie is so much more worse than a
normal wedgie are you kidding me
no way would you rather only breakfast
cereal or only eat pasta
well questions you have landed on the
only two things I eat in life these days
instant microwavable pasta and freakin
cereal this just shows how sad my life
has become would you rather have
stretchable legs or have stretchable
arms okay this is where things get
really bizarre because you can either
reach out and punch people or reach out
and grab the soda from across the room
which is more like what I would do I
would snake my arm all the way
downstairs to the fridge and grab
something to eat and pull it back
probably either pasta or cereal one of
the two or you can have stretchable legs
and you can kick someone from really far
away or you can look like you're walking
on stilts as you go around town I'll
leave this one up to you so choose I
don't know which I'd pick but you guys
know which one you'd pick so write down
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see
woody woody woody